if you
[Music]
want
ex where's our daughter yes please where
is Kamala wherever you were where were
you who's Cala the third person we're
switching with light Powers teenage girl
where were you what are you doing what
are you doing I'm trying to switch isn't
it working I to
work
where are we going and why are we going
there where you
going uhoh Monica you got to fly no no
no I I mean I know but technically I
haven't done that yet yeah well you got
to now or Camala is not going to
graduate from high school come on use
your core
[Music]
oh hey black girl
magic I got you I got you I got you I
got
you
oops out of here I can't hold on to you
while I'm
flying oh my God oh my God we're going
to die hold on I'm thinking I'm thinking
I have an idea come on to
me
[Music]
there oh it's cool it's
Carol hey no powers no powers
just
who are they they are Associates of
Captain
Marvel the annihilator here oh yeah well
she was and then these two just sort of
appeared what about the band if she's
medling I need to strike now yeah I
still can't account for the instability
exhibited on m41a this thing does much
more than just but it
works yes yes but if you give me more
time I can make it safer no no we do it
now before the annihilator
appears
uh what should we do
about these
two
you hold that
[Music]
thought
we got to get that band off of her it
looks like mine
guys
I can't
fly do you guys have a spaceship I could
borrow or Camala don't talk to them you
know my
name the cre came here hopeful that we
could build a covenant of Peace what
have you done but then you sick the
annihilator on
us like we're
verman once again the scroll have
betrayed the
cre and for
that
Carol we got to get these people out of
here Emperor Dro you need to evacuate
your people
now we have nowhere to
go
here the
ships they're not going to make
it get back to the ship and don't use
your powers but I can help
now
[Music]
there
[Applause]
[Music]
where's
Camala Camala
[Applause]
[Music]
no let's go let's
go
[Music]
come
on keep moving please
please all these people they're going to
come on sweetie no how could you here we
need to save who we
can
transmission sent
hey this peace
treaty it was a good
thing it was a ruse if it were your
intervention failed we don't need your
help
anymore I called a friend she can find a
safe place for
you is that okay
we have no
choice
incoming